I think it's, you know,
it's scary at times
because you really are
potentially influencing
the way hundreds of millions
of people think a month.
Yair Livne,
thank you so much for joining me.
How are you?
Good, how are you?
Wonderful.
Where are you calling from right now?
I'm in Palo Alto.
You're in Palo Alto.
And I have to congratulate you
on a pretty big transition
right after many years of Quora.
Also quite a few years,
at least 4 years VP of Product.
You've recently finished
your service there.
And you're on to some different things.
And I'd love to chat
about your experience with Quora
and some of the really
interesting things that you've done,
both that are mainstream today,
but also that weren't
necessarily mainstream back
when you were working on them.
But I'd like to start
all the way back,
going back to Stanford.
You're doing your PhD
over there in economics
and you're working
on some really interesting things
that I just love,
both matching theory
and political economy.
Tell me a little bit about yourself
and what led you to do
that research at Stanford.
Yeah.
A great question.
So, I'm curious about economics
for years before coming to Stanford.
I was doing my BA and master's
at the Hebrew U and Jerusalem.
And was mixing
math and econ throughout.
And I was really interested in this
kind of intersection where
the theory and kind of the beauty
of mathematics can be applied
to real world problems.
Maybe like the epitome of that
is Auction Theory,
which won the Nobel Prize
a few weeks ago.
It was kind of motivating,
kind of energy coming in.
I actually had the chance
to be in quite a few lectures
by Milgrom this past year.
And I have to say
that I didn't understand much,
but it was still
fascinating nevertheless.
Yeah, I was in a reading room
with him for kind of a couple of years.
And it was really fascinating
to kind of see him like think
and kind of
appreciate his point of view
on the world.
It's quite extraordinary.
So, you've doing your research.Yeah.
Yeah.
Anyway, so, I got curious.
What else what other kind
of beautiful mathematical applications
can be used
to understand the world
or maybe improve the world.
And kind of matching markets was
a really fascinating thing.
It was kind of blowing up.
And within economics at the time,
people were innovating on matching theory
to do things like kidney donations
and matching kids to schools
in a really efficient way.
And some of those kind of techniques
were actually implemented then
in the kidney donation market
or in actual school systems like
in Boston, in New York,
which were changing
how they were running things,
using economic theory
and with economists
as kind of the people
planning these systems.
So, that was kind
of how I got pulled
into this area.
So, I have to spend
some time talking about
the beauty of mathematics
and, you know, and enlighten
both myself and a lot of my viewers
that aren't necessarily leaning
into the mathematical world.
I am, but I know a lot of my friends
who are excited about innovation
aren't leaning there.
How does mathematics play a role
into our lives,
whether it's matching theory
or political economy?
I'd love to really understand
this world a little bit better
and show some of the excitement.
Yeah.
So, for me, a lot of it comes from
and I think that's kind of
the modern way
to view economics
is from incentives.
So, if you can
describe with a little bit of math,
it doesn't need to be
super sophisticated
what people's preferences are
and what kind of outcomes they prefer.
Then you can model the world
again, with fairly simple primitives
and use this description
of incentives to predict behavior.
And if you can predict behavior,
then you can go one step higher
and describe what kind of systems
would actually push forward
better behavior
on the part of economic agents.
So, in the case of,
let's say, school choice,
if people have preferences over schools
and they want to be matched
with a specific school for their kid,
and that might involve
many different types
of considerations, like
what are your, you know,
the other kids in the family,
are they going already
to school within the system.
What kind of focus areas
that that school have
and is that a good match
for their child or not.
How close is the school
to where they live.
And kind of model all of that out.
And again, this is not rocket science.
This is just a fairly simple
ways of creating kind of
list of preferences.
Then you can think of,
okay, if I ask people
and have incentives
that are aligned in the sense that
the system
will actually respect your preferences
and give you the best outcome
for the preferences you stated,
then you can think
of designing these systems
in a way where matching is "optimal"
and you can get the best outcomes
for the most like
the largest amount of people.
So, that's for me,
really neat thing
where you can take
mathematical models
and kind of solve them in a way
which generate better outcomes for people
in their real lives, on the things
that matter most to them.
100%.
And I have to say
that I've been getting exposed
to the process of residency
and doctors, people in medical school
that are getting there.
You know, on one hand it seems,
yes, matching is a problem.
It's a little bit longer.
Sometimes it's not ideal.
But then, when you meet
the person that's actually
going through that process
and this is not
a life threatening situation.
Right?
Like kidney donations
or stuff like that.
But you can still see
the impact of what
mathematics and algorithms
can do to help ease the process,
let alone save lives.
That is beautiful as you mentioned.
That is beautiful mathematics.
And I'm extremely excited
to continue my studies
and get to those levels.
And then what about
the political economy?
How does math play into politics
and what's coming there?
Yeah. So, fun fact there is I got pulled
into it through my wife,
who is also doing a PhD
at Stanford at the same time.
And she was in
the political science department,
but actually had a very similar background
from a kind of game theory
and mathematics perspective.
And we were both kind of curious.
This is like again,
really good timing
because we were doing this
kind of pre Arab Spring.
But we got really curious
on this topic of protests,
especially protests
in authoritarian regimes.
So, these are people
who are taking a big chance
and risking their lives
and going to voice their concerns
or their objections
to the regime under the threat
of arrest or execution.
And why are they doing that?
What kind of dynamics contribute
to them taking that chance?
What are they looking
to get out of it?
And so, we were using
a kind of a mix approach
of both looking at empirical data,
but also building
a mathematical model
that would try to explain
under what conditions,
would people actually take that chance
and again, take on meaningful cost
to get an outcome.
And that outcome is political.
And so it kind of reached
a model where, you know,
the economic conditions were often
a strong determinant
of when protests might happen.
And what's the probability
of that protest actually having an impact.
And again, the timing
was really opportune
because we were doing this just before
the kind of Arab Spring
where we saw this actually play out
with many, many regimes
being toppled or at least shaken
by mass protest movements,
something that wasn't seen
for basically decades.
So, when we were
originally taking on this research,
it was kind of out of vague
to study protest
because it was like
this never happens
or this isn't meaningful.
And then, a year or two later
we saw all of this unfold.
So, it was really
kind of a fun experience
to be thinking about these problems.
So, Yair, you're working on these
mathematical models.
You're thinking about all this
and all of a sudden, the Arab Spring happens,
and you're watching this.
And I have to get into
the perspective that you're at,
I believe, it's like 2010, 2011.
Right?
How does this all play out?
Are you surprised?
Does this research take on a greater role?
What happens there?
Yeah.
So I, we definitely were surprised.
Again, this was not something
that we had seen since probably
the fall of the Soviet Union,
where people work on toppling regimes
by going out into the streets.
So, it was a shock.
I mean, it is kind of very relevant
or eerily similar to
what the dynamics we described
in our papers,
because ultimately the logic
was kind of very simple.
Things get kind of bad enough
from an economic perspective
where people are desperate enough,
they'll take that chance.
That was the heart of the model.
But really connecting it to the empirics
and actually kind of being able
to predict, this was
the neat part of the research.
And so, it was both surprising,
but very kind of consistent,
at the same time.
And I kind of, both my wife and I were in
the process of kind of leaving academia.
But for the professor
we were working with
in the political science department,
this was a very good boost
for her career.
Unbelievable.
So, you're at that point,
you're leaving academia
and you have a series
of different experiences throughout
your professional career
leading up to your job at Quora now.
I know Quora
as this beautiful website
that I go to, to answer
all of the relevant
and irrelevant questions
that I may have.
But walk me through
a little bit of your life path
that led to being VP of Product
at such an awesome company.
Yeah.
So, it may seem random,
but I think there is
a thread connecting everything,
or at least I'd like to believe so.
So for me,
kind of what I've enjoyed
or what I've been attracted to is
how do we kind of
again, use kind of math
or logic to unlock a lot of value.
And that's something
that's kind of always driven me
or I was passionate about.
And with Quora as an economist,
this is actually a fascinating thing
to dive into because
you can think about Quora,
and I think this is true of knowledge
more generally as a market.
There are people who need
certain answers to certain questions.
Those may be very important or trivial.
That's all fine.
And the other people in the world
who know about the answers to those
and kind of how do you connect
the two sides of this market
and how do you unlock value
and how do you create
the right incentives for people
to be kind of sharing
that online in a public way.
That was like the key question
that motivated me.
And actually my first project
I got put on was
we had what to consider
the time that we later
deprecated called Quora Credits,
which was a way for people
to accumulate kind of virtual money.
This is kind of pre Bitcoin.
Everything about virtual money.
So, accumulate this
kind of point system
and be able to spend it
by asking people directly
for their answers on a question.
So, you basically got an ability
to kind of buy someone's attention
by sending them a notification
and an email saying,
hey, can you answer this question.
And so each person
had kind of a dynamic price
of how much is their attention worth.
And that was based
on supply and demand
dynamics in the marketplace.
And again, if you are
a good member of the community
and you supply value yourself,
then you were able
to kind of utilize that
and kind of get value
or get knowledge
out of somebody else's head.
That was kind of
a beautiful concept to me.
And something that really pulled me
into working for the company.
Wow.
So, you know,
a marketplace of knowledge
in an age of misinformation.
You know,
you're VP of Product, I believe,
all the way back from 2016.
Right?
You're seeing what has happened
with the election
and when I look on social media
and those sorts of areas,
it's very hard for me
not to be pessimistic about,
about where we're headed with,
with misinformation.
And it's almost like a promise to myself
that I'll only really accept knowledge
when I see it cross sectioning
from various sources,
and I take pride in that.
But how do you,
as VP of Product,
approach this mentality
that we have a real issue
on our hands
and it's growing exponentially?
Right?
I mean, it's getting out of control.
Yeah. That's a great question.
And I think for us, like,
while we were actually very
kind of in some sense validated
by all of this happening,
that this is kind of sounds ironic.
But we at that point
had been worried about, you know,
kind of misinformation
or just generally what's true or not
for many years.
For us, you know,
our mission is to share
and grow the world's knowledge.
And by that we mean real knowledge
that is useful to people.
Misinformation is something that undermines,
as you were saying,
people's trust and knowledge.
So, for us,
that was an existential threat
if the platform can be manipulated
into showing prominently
or spreading information,
that's not actually true.
That undermines trust
in the platform.
That reduces the incentive
for people to start search for knowledge.
And because of this marketplace
that I was describing,
it also reduces the incentives
of good people to actually share
the right information
because there's all this
other junk out there
that might drown out
what they are saying
or what they are sharing.
So for us, we were thinking
about this problem years earlier.
One of the key moments for me
in that journey was
we had to digest email
or still have to digest email.
It's a more popular kind of
emails out there that go out
and hundreds of millions of people
and has personalized information for them,
something we had invested a lot in.
And there was
I believe this was in 2014 or 2015,
we had sent out
to, if I remember correctly,
hundreds of thousands
or a few million people
and answer at the top
of their email
that had basically kind of
a 9/11 conspiracy theory content in it
like feature prominently.
And that was like
a real wake up moment
of hey, we're
approaching this purely algorithmically
with all these algorithms that
trying to understand what people like,
but we do this on
the basis of fairly kind
of shallow signals like
clicks and uploads,
we may fall into these traps.
And we really have
to put in some guardrails
and make sure that we don't let
that kind of, "information to take over".
And so, we have been thinking
about this for years
before the election
and for us kind of seeing
the rest of the industry
suddenly realized, hey,
there's a massive kind of problem here
and we should start kind of
being a lot more careful
about "free speech",
was again, validating in some sense
because we had been working
on this for years.
Wow. That's a lot of responsibility,
isn't it?
To sit in that chair and understand that
the things that you're working on
are the core of information?
Absolutely.
I mean, I think it's scary at times
because you really are
potentially influencing
the way hundreds of millions
of people think a month
and that those, you know,
subtle nudges towards
believing things aren't true
are risky from a political perspective,
social stability perspective,
medical advice,
like all these areas
are hyper important to people's lives.
And if you're pushing
the wrong stuff out there,
that is the opposite of our mission.
That is dangerous.
And so, that's kind
of a fear or concern.
Again, we were occupied
with for a long time.
And it's just to call that
and be kind of a little charitable
to other platforms
is a really kind of tricky area.
You don't want to,
it's very hard to
be the voice of truth
and be an arbiter of every little fact.
We're talking about millions
and millions of answers a week.
What's true or not.
Nobody can kind of sift through that
and make a decision.
You even saw this
with the pandemic
where the early information
that the most credible agencies
were pushing out was actually false.
And at that time
is very hard to make that call.
So, you need to strike this balance
of allowing debate
and allowing enough spectrum of views
to kind of have its fight out there
and kind of have that evolution of ideas.
But at the same time,
the stuff that's
kind of intentionally false
or deliberately misleading
or is kind of the conspiracy theory realm,
have a really hard line there
and have the mechanisms in place
where you can squash that when it arises.
So, it's really unfair
that I'm asking you this
when we have literally
a minute and a half
to the interview,
but where are we headed?
What needs to happen
so that when I watch
as I watch my niece,
who is six years old,
as she grows up
and she gets more
into social media
and she's so curious,
how can I help her?
How can the world help her
gain curiosity in the right way?
Yeah. I think that's
a really key question.
And I think that, you know,
this is a really interesting
intersection of regulation,
kind of a corporate responsibility
on the side of platforms.
And frankly,
a lot more, I think, debate
that needs to happen there.
So, I don't have like a magic bullet,
but I do think platforms need to spend
a lot more thought and time about
kind of striking that balance
and making sure their algorithms
don't kind of trend
or have these feedback loops
that end up in these places
where people become
convinced of flat earth theories for real.
Because of like some rabbit hole
they went down through YouTube.
So, I honestly think
that the right solution
is some regulation,
potentially not a massive amount,
but a lot more
kind of corporate effort
to kind of squash these pockets
of the Internet that are really dangerous.
Right. And we've obviously seen
the sensitivity behind this,
the intersection between regulation
and private companies
and what's happening,
especially as we've seen
in the most recent election,
as some of Twitter's action,
some of Facebook's actions that
even a single action could
like flagging a comment by
an official in the White House says
something that maybe not correct,
that stirs up
some very meaningful
conversations about the foundation
of what is the responsibility
of these private companies.
As well as what is the responsibility
for their own company,
but also for the citizens
and for the integrity
of a free and fair election
or democracy.
Yair, I want to thank you
for being so kind with your time
and so generous.
I can go on this
for another two hours
because everything
that we've touched here
is so fascinating
and so remarkable.
So, thank you for sharing that with me.
Before we leave,
I have to ask you
for three words
that you would use
to describe yourself.
Optimistic,
persistent and curious.
So, after all of that,
optimistic, persistent and curious.
I just love it.
Thank you so much, Yair.
This was just wonderful. Toda raba.
Thank you so much.